why I say there are many wives in
sheep's clothing that have never taught
their daughters how to be a wife and so
what we have is Generation after
generation after generation of women
that are selfish what is this scream it
says I want him to do something for me
therefore I am going to withhold sex to
get what I want relationships like that
do not work and honestly if I were G I
think men should sue for fraud I really
do I think men should be able to sue
their wives for
fraud they get married they they're
going to have sex and then the woman
just pulls one over and has does this to
them and guys this is so emasculating to
a guy this is men men want you to want
to be with them they don't they don't
want to you know how mascula it is to
provide and protect for a woman only to
have her belittle you in this way and
women think this is funny